(upbeat music)
- Hello, there.
It's me, Dave, your friendly
neighborhood YouTube host.
And according to the red
light that I see a little up
unto the right of me, I
am live on the YouTube.
It's true people, I have been
off the grid without news,
without information,
without current events,
without technology for 32 days.
That is right.
I got a bonus day.
There were 31 days in
August, but I got a bonus day
because we started this on a Saturday
after I left in a blaze
of glory on a Friday.
As you all may remember,
let's just recap some stuff for ya'.
In about 10 minutes from now,
I'm bringing in Adam Carolla
who is going to get me
caught up on everything.
I have literally no idea
what's going on in the world.
I don't know what's going
on on the COVID front.
I don't know if Joe
Biden is still president.
I don't know anything.
It was actually quite easy to
stay off the grid this year.
And I'll sorta let you
know why in a minute
and then just in these first 10 minutes,
I wanna frame a little bit of about
how I'm gonna go ahead doing this show
and doing everything
that I do going forward,
because I've had a month to think about it
and think about how I want to
continue doing some things,
change some things, some
new thoughts that I had
over the course of the
month, et cetera, et cetera.
But just to quickly recap,
I left in a complete blaze of glory
because you may remember the
day before I left the grid,
I was banned by Twitter for
misinformation about COVID
because I said something about
how eventually they're going
to want COVID mandates, vaccine mandates,
and that obviously the
vaccines aren't working the way
they were promised.
I was banned temporarily on
Twitter for misinformation,
but I fought back and
I got a bunch of people
to fight back on my behalf.
And basically the last
thing that happened to me
before I went off the grid
for the next month was
that Twitter actually
reversed their decision
and sent me an email
saying it was an error.
So not only did that happen,
the day that I left the grid,
the last day of July, but
I also released the presale
for my new book, "Don't
Burn this Country".
It hit number one on
Amazon movers and shakers.
So I was feeling great. I was just like,
"If you're ever gonna leave,
like, this is the way to do it."
Beat Twitter, like have
Twitter say that you're a liar
and then get them to retract it,
and then get your book out there
and hit number one on the Amazon charts.
I was feeling real good, okay?
And then what did we do?
Well, the next day, David
and I hopped on a plane
and we went to the rain forest in Mexico
and we're there for two weeks.
And all we did was eat
fish, a lot of ceviche,
a lot of fajitas, a
significant amount of tequila
and rest on the beach,
hang out in the rain forest
with the animals, watch
the storms at night,
just completely decompressed.
So before I get to any of the specifics
on how I'm gonna do
the show going forward,
and some of the new thoughts I
have, I just want to quickly,
and I did a little locals
live stream earlier
for our members over there.
I just want to say to you guys,
to anyone watching this right now,
to anyone that supports me in any way,
that clicks these videos,
you click Like, click Share,
whatever, if I'm part of
your life in any little way,
however insignificant
or significant it is,
I am beyond full of thanks right now.
Like I really, really just
had the best month of my life.
And I don't know that anyone
on this planet earth had
a better month than I did.
Like we ate right, we
listened to great music,
I exercised every day.
I'm truly, right now, I'm
probably in the best shape
I've been in about 15 years.
But I mean that not only
physically, but mentally,
I mean it spiritually as well.
I just feel good, I feel ready to fight.
I don't know what I've missed.
I suspect that when I bring
on Carolla in a few minutes,
he's not gonna have the long list
of great things that happened,
that's not really the way
the news works anymore.
Like, "Yes, we did actually
stop critical race theory
and yes, social justice has done.
And the neo-racism that
they're pushing on everyone
and the destruction of
all of our institutions,
it's all been reversed,
everything's okay."
Like I know that's not coming, right?
God only knows what COVID,
but I don't even think
with COVID, it's not like
he's gonna suddenly say,
"It's wrapped up."
And I know a little bit about
that because in the two weeks
that I've been back here in LA,
it's like everyone's masked up again.
So I can't imagine anything
good is happening on that front,
whether that's the reality
of what's going on with COVID
or just the media version of it
or whatever people wanna
believe or any of that stuff.
But I really just had an
absolutely incredible month
and I just joined genuinely
thank you guys for that.
And I have to say that when I
was away the first two weeks
and we were in Mexico, there
were a lot of fans that were
at the resort and people would
come up and say hi to me.
And everyone was respectful
and everyone knows I'm off
the grid so no one tried
to talk politics with me
or anything like that.
Couple of people would
be like, "Come on, Dave,
you've got your phone,
you've got your phone."
I'd pull out my pockets,
I've done this every year,
"No, I got nothing with me."
And people were great.
And people always say the same thing.
I said this on the locals
live stream earlier.
They always now say the same thing to me,
which is, "Dave, you keep me sane."
And it's like that's a
really interesting thing
for people to say to somebody.
Like, if you go up to comedian,
"You're the funniest guy in the world."
Or you go up to Jordan
Peterson and you go,
"You helped me turn my life around."
You go up to somebody that's
influenced you in some way,
an actor that you love,
"I love your movies."
But like for people to come up
to you and consistently say,
"You helped me stay sane,"
something to that effect.
I don't even know how to describe
what that's like in a way,
because in some ways you've
helped me stay sane too, right?
Like when I do this show in
some ways, this is a mirror,
like I put some stuff back,
I put some stuff out there
and then it sort of bounces off
you guys and then comes back
to me and and then I do it again tomorrow
and I try to figure
out, what's the best way
to have people not go crazy?
I don't want people to go crazy.
I just had this great
month and that's really
what I wanna sort of
incorporate in going forward.
So I have six quick things
that I want to talk about.
And then I promise, we're
bringing in Carolla,
he'll get me caught up on everything.
But I had six sort of
thoughts over the last month
that I thought were worth
addressing right now
before I know any of the news,
just things that I've been thinking about.
So first off, I just want
to say something on the COVID front.
Now again, I suspect things are
probably not going great right now
'cause I'm seeing masks everywhere,
even when people are walking dogs again.
But on the COVID front in a broad sense,
I'm gonna go out on a
limb right now and say
that no state failed.
Did any state in the United States fail
or did any country failed?
Is India still a country?
Did a little village in Chad,
somewhere in Africa fail because of COVID?
Has any hospital anywhere failed?
Now, I'm not saying COVID is
not real and all of that stuff,
but when you step away from
the day-to-day minutiae
about masks and mandates and
lockdowns and everything else,
like were there any discussions
in the last month about health?
I ate really well in this last month.
I worked out every single day.
For the two weeks that we
were in the rainforest,
we did the sauna, the steam room,
and a cold plunge pool
every day for about an hour.
I feel like a million bucks right now.
I suspect I probably have a
little bit of a better immunity,
natural immunity in my system right now
as a healthy person than
I did before I went off.
Was there any discussion
on that CNN on MSNBC,
any of these places about
just taking care of yourself
and health and natural immunity?
And if not, why not?
And how is it that no hospital,
like I'm gonna just make a
guess here, an educated guess,
no hospital in the United
States has failed yet.
Not one failure, like that
to say there aren't stresses,
but like there's something
about the narrative
that just ain't right.
I don't know all the
answers to all of that,
those questions, why these things are,
but that was one of the
questions I was thinking
about directly related to COVID.
The other thing that I
was thinking a lot about.
And I think over the
next, however many months
and years that I continue to do this show,
you guys will help me figure this out is,
what do we do about the liars?
One of the things that I always
talk about on the show is
that we are just in this
endless assault on truth
that we just get lied
to over and over again.
Whether it's that this
election bill is racist
or that Brett Kavanaugh's a serial rapist
or the litany of things
that they're always,
half the country is white
supremacist, whatever it is.
It's like, we have it to figure out
what do we do about the liars?
And I don't know that just
countering the lies is enough.
This is something I talk a lot about.
And the reason I was thinking
about it particularly
in the of this month
is, although I was not
on my phone doing a lot of
things, when I was doing cardio,
I was sometimes watching YouTube
and I usually watch old sports games,
but sometimes ads would pop up
and because we're in the
midst of this recall here
in California, which
I think is going well,
if I'm not mistaken, I have
a little evidence on that,
there are all of these
ads on the YouTube videos
that are filled with
lies about Larry Elder.
That's how I know that
the recall is going well,
because they're now attacking Larry Elder.
They're all funded by the way,
by this guy, Reed Hastings,
who's the CEO of Netflix.
And it's like, you just
are willing to lie.
Basically imply that Larry
elder is some far right nutbag
and a white supremacist
and everything else.
And it was just making
me think, well, it's not
that they just lie to us about
COVID and all these things,
but they're lying, yes, Larry
Elder is a white supremacist.
Like what are we gonna do about the liars?
That was something that
I thought a lot about.
And that sort of brought
me to the third thing,
which is that because I talk
about this war on truth a lot,
what I've realized is we're
really in a digital war,
it's basically the digital world
versus the world real world.
And that is sort of the war
that we're facing right now.
The way misinformation
can spread digitally
and how that now affects real world things
so that you can spread some misinformation
or whatever you want to
call it, about COVID.
Next thing you're shutting
down real businesses
and you're locking people at home,
which then forces them to spend
more of their time online.
And we have less interactions face-to-face
and we do everything with masks.
Like COVID and masks really had nothing
to do with my life over the last month.
I had a great month.
I spoke to real people.
Actually, when we were at this resort,
the guests did not have to
wear masks, but the staff did.
And I made sure to say to
every single staff member,
every single day, that if you
want to take your mask down
when you're talking to me
that that's just fine with me,
and they wouldn't do it because
they want to keep their job.
And there were cameras around.
One guy actually did.
But at the end we had these two people
that were sort of working
with us most of the time
and I got them to just
quickly do it just to smile.
But think about that.
We had two people that were, in fact,
they were like our butlers,
so you can just call them
if you wanted to get something.
And it was like, I didn't see
these people for two weeks,
their faces, I got them
to smile at the end.
And that is leading to, I would say,
a digital world verse real world war.
And we're going to have
to figure that out.
Like the digital stuff is now leaking
into absolutely everything.
And then they lock you down
and they keep you home,
they keep you addicted to these things.
They can manipulate the algorithm
so they can make you
think all sorts of things.
And guess what guys, when
you let it go for a month,
it seems pretty clear,
which sort of leads me
to the next thing, which
is also COVID related,
which is that COVID at this point,
and again, no matter what
I'm about to hear from Adam
and whatever has happened this month,
and I'm not saying it doesn't exist,
and actually I know somebody
that got COVID last week
and they were sick for three
days and then they were better.
And by the way, I was at a family wedding
in Jersey a few days ago, and
it was to see actual people,
and some people wore masks
and some people didn't.
I didn't, some people did.
It's okay, everyone made the decisions.
I don't think it was gonna be
a super spreader event or not.
As far as I know, nobody died.
But COVID is also not just a virus anymore
in the traditional sense of virus.
But I would also say it's
a virus in the system
for whenever things get too hot.
I thought a lot about this.
For the last couple of years,
we've been told that
half of us are racists,
half of us are white supremacists,
all of that nonsense.
And it started not to work anymore.
It was becoming a meme,
it was becoming thin.
It just wasn't working,
like it's just not true
and it wasn't working the way
that it did work for a long time.
Like we were able to laugh at it.
The New York Times would
call me a white supremacist
and that it was like a joke
more than anything else.
But now COVID is that new
thing that's in the system,
whenever it gets too hot,
whatever it is, it's like,
they could be like, "All right,
we got the delta variant,
we got the gamma variant, now
we got to lock you down again.
We got to shut down your business again."
So it's never really going away.
I mean, I think that's what I've come to.
Now, if I'm completely off on
this, I suppose it's possible,
maybe I'm completely off.
I'm gonna talk to Adam in two minutes
and he's gonna tell me COVID is over,
but I suspect I am not wrong on that.
And I think I've just one
or two more things for ya'.
This is an idea that I thought a lot about
before I went off the
grid and it's something
that I've been talking
about for about a year,
but it really seems now obvious to me.
The old world isn't coming back
and I think we really have to accept that.
Like the old world, that
world of say January, 2020
right before COVID, which was pretty good,
it ain't coming back.
Like the whole thing has changed.
And look how quickly the
entire world changed.
Does your life, does the
way you look at the world,
does it all feel way
different than it did then?
Do things seem better or worse?
Is your life better or worse?
Are you personally better or worse,
are your relationships better or worse?
Like all of these things,
it's just not coming back,
and I think it's important for
us to figure out which pieces
of that old world we wanna
take with us to the new world
'cause the new world is coming,
whether we like it or not,
and I think we really
have to figure that out.
And that brings me to the
last thing that I was thinking
about, and then I'll just say
one other thing personally,
and then bring on Adam, which
is that I think probably,
and I see no way around this
at this point, we kind of are
in a cold civil war at
this point, ideologically.
Like there are a set of people
that want to burn it down
that have said that they
don't wanna negotiate.
Like that this is the way the world is
and America is evil and
Western values are evil,
capitalism, all of these things.
And then there's these other people
who just wanna kinda live and let live
and understand that the
human experience is filled
with inconsistencies and a constant battle
to better ourselves,
but that there's nothing really perfect.
Those things kind of can't
exist together, right?
Like if one set of people is saying,
"Let's see what we can
do and fix on the margins
and expand freedoms and
things are kind of messy
and we can agree to disagree,"
but then this other sort of
cult-like ideology is like,
"No, it's our way or the highway,
or our way or we're
gonna destroy your cities
or our way or we're gonna
take all your stuff."
It's like that doesn't really work.
And the idea that you'd have
liberals versus conservatives,
people who want to change
things on the margins
versus just people who want
things to stay the same.
It's like, "All right,
that tension is good
and sometimes it leans this way
and sometimes lean this way,
but now we're into something else."
And because I've come to that belief,
I really wanna focus on building things.
That's what I've done with locals.
I wanna find more of you
that are building your own businesses,
that are building new institutions
and I wanna help you however I can,
and that's really where
a lot of my energy is.
So last thing before I bring in Carolla,
look, I did not have this thing on me
basically for the month.
I had to take a couple of phone
calls and my mom's dog died,
Charlie, little shout out to Charlie.
Like I did hear a couple
things related to that,
but I was not in the constant war.
I was not in this endless
doom scrolling of Twitter
and what did these people say?
And even like, I really
didn't think about AOC
for a month, which truly is a joy.
I didn't think about any of that stuff.
I just enjoyed myself most
days at the end of the day,
Dave and I, we got a big green egg.
We smoked an incredible amount of briskets
and tri tips and tomahawks,
and we ate great.
Just everything we ate was great
and took care of ourselves.
And most nights when
my head hit the pillow,
I would say to him, "I
had a great day today.
What a great day it was today."
And I believe that all
of us can have that.
Maybe you can't have it for
a month so consistently.
And I thank all of you guys
for letting me do this crazy thing
that I've now done for five years.
But that's the feeling
that I want to go forward.
Like, how do we balance
being engaged people,
being part of this new
digital world that is here,
whether we like it or not versus while,
or I should say, while at
the same time, being happy,
being real people in a
real world with people
and dealing with that tension.
So that being said, I'm here, I'm open,
I am now going to hear from Adam Carolla,
who's gonna get me caught
up to speed on the world,
assuming it still exists.
And let's see what I missed.
I guess I'm a little, it's not nervous,
but I'm a little trepidatious, let's say.
Carolla, are you there?
- I am.
- Carolla, that was my
little Dave Rubin oration
to begin this thing.
I'm feeling pretty good about life.
I make a good steak
normally, but I ate well,
I listened to music, I worked
out, I'm feeling good, man.
I sense you might wreck
the whole thing here.
- Yeah, well, I'm with
you on your philosophy.
And I do tell people all the time,
now you just held your phone
up to show the audience.
I couldn't hold my phone up
because I don't have
my phone in the studio.
So for little tips for ins for sanity is
I never bring my phone in my studio
because there's nothing I can
do with it while I'm in here.
It's just a distraction.
And the rule is I'm in
the studio hours a day
and there's never a phone in here.
So it's all gonna have to wait.
And if you sort of make
some of those rules
for yourself, it's a better life.
All right.
- I'm telling you, man,
just not having my phone
in the morning, I try not to
bring the phone in the bedroom,
even normally when I'm not off the grid,
but just knowing that I'm waking up,
I don't know what time it is
and I'm not gonna just see
what someone said about me
on Twitter as the first thing
in the morning and it's not
gonna be the thing I end with,
but just that alone is a game changer.
- Yeah, to answer your question, which is,
why isn't the media talking
about diet and exercise
and body mass index and
obesity and all these things,
which is interesting that, other than age,
the second most important
part of not being killed
by COVID is obesity and
they never bring up age
or obesity by the way.
So obviously, what it is with
diet, exercise, supplements,
and the things you've been speaking about
and therapeutics, which they just poo-poo.
If they talked about diet and exercise,
that would give you control,
meaning you're in control
over what you put in your
mouth, you're controlled
over how long you run on
the treadmill, if at all.
That gives you control.
They don't want to give you any control,
they want all the control.
So anything that has to do
with you and your own control,
being the captain of your own
ship, they never talk about,
and they don't wanna relinquish
a second of it to you.
- So are you saying I'm right
that not one hospital failed
while I was gone and no country failed,
the little village somewhere in Africa
that maybe doesn't have the protections
that we have here in Los
Angeles, none of that happened?
I'm right?
- Well, every time I turn on
CNN, they're always talking
about the ICU's bursting at the scenes,
but they never break,
you know what I mean?
They're somehow about to
burst, but they never burst.
And if you talk to Dr. Drew about it,
when they give you a lot of those
our hospitals are filled to capacity,
they're always talking
about the county hospitals.
There's hundreds of private hospitals
and those aren't filled to capacity.
So they leave that part out.
So essentially saying
county USC is filled,
but not St Joseph's up the
street or Cedars down the street.
So be careful when you hear them talk
about who's bursting at the scene.
- Well, I don't want to lead you.
So if you don't want to start with COVID,
you can tell me absolutely anything.
And again, truly, I know nothing, nothing
that has happened in the month.
- Well, as long as we're on a COVID,
well, I'll tell you what
we'll circle back to COVID.
We'll start with the
Taliban invaded Afghanistan
and Biden withdrew the troops
and the airport was overrun
and there's incredible
video, and we'll show it
in a few minutes, there's
incredible video of folks clinging
to the aircraft and clinging
to the landing gear,
literally last helicopter out of Hanoi.
It's reminiscent of that.
- It's our people escaping?
- This is, sorry, Afghani
refugees hanging on
to our planes trying to get out of there
because the Taliban overran the,
so basically the Taliban
was in charge of security
at the airport,
essentially, the perimeter.
The entire place was overrun by Taliban
and we had Americans
trying to get out of there
and interpreters and folks
that were friendly to us
during the last 20 years of that skirmish,
and it was a total bleep show
and so we actually had to send
troops back into Afghanistan
to go to that airport and
try to extract Americans
and folks that were
considered friendly to us,
although we're of course not successful
in getting everyone out.
- So we got some people out
and did you say now we're
taking our troops out?
Like, is it done?
I mean, if the idea here--
- They're done.
- So we're officially leaving Afghanistan?
There were some rumblings
about that sort of
at the end of July.
I mean, it's the longest
war in American history.
I'm completely fine with ending that war.
- Yeah, so what happened was,
and in terms of the narrative, is I think
most all Democrats and
many Republicans say,
"Let's get out Afghanistan.
Why do we need to keep this going?"
Now, if you listen to
guys like Ben Shapiro,
they'll say we had 2500 troops there
and nobody had died in a year and a half,
so is that really an endless war?
And he makes a good point.
Like we have troops stationed
in Japan and Germany.
We have troops around the world,
but they're not involved
with an endless war,
they're just there, you know?
And so to kind of paint it as
not another American killed,
the sons and daughters
are going over there
and never coming back, it's
not totally accurate because
in the last seven, they lost 10 people.
We always have to say,
it's always a tragedy,
anyone lost blah, blah, blah, understood.
But if you have no fatalities
in the last year and a half,
is that an endless war?
- Right, so what's, what's the
main media narrative on this?
Is it that it was somehow a failure
of the Biden administration
that we lost this airfield
and had to leave?
And I mean, I got to see the
video here obviously, but like,
is that with the narrative
or is the narrative like,
"Biden is doing what Trump never did,"
or something like that?
- Well, the media has a
couple of stratus to it.
So the first is Biden is pulling
everyone out, good for him.
Second one was, it turned
into such a cluster F
that even CNN couldn't ignore it.
You know what I mean?
You can't ignore, I should
run the video for you.
- Interesting.
- You can ignore a
video of people clinging
to the landing gear of a C130 aircraft.
- Yeah, wait, real quick
though, before we throw
to the video, so that's
interesting though.
Did they basically try
to ignore it at first,
the mainstream media
'cause he was gonna make
the administration look bad?
Like it was going around
Twitter and the rest of it
and then eventually they just
couldn't ignore it anymore?
- No, they didn't do
what they normally do,
which is ignored for as long as they can
because it happened so quickly
and literally overnight.
And there was so much
dramatic footage coming
from that region that even
CNN couldn't ignore it.
They all had to jump into it.
They then kind of
corrected their narrative.
And I'll explain that momentarily.
But I think first we should
take a look at the video
of the Kabul airport and the tarmac
and people trying to flee.
So we'll show that.
- [Male Journalist] Taliban
fighters took control
of the capital less than 20 years
after US forces overthrew
their government.
Afghanistan's president fled the country
and much of the population is
in hiding afraid of what's next.
- [Female Journalist]
With scenes like this
and unable to get on a
flight, we decided to stay.
Taliban fighters soon
declared an end to the war
from the comfort of the
presidential palace,
just hours after strolling into Kabul,
just 11 days after launching an offensive,
overwhelming US trained Afghan forces
in cities across Afghanistan.
(people shouting)
(plane engine roaring)
(sirens wailing)
- Holy shit, that aircraft.
- There's dramatic footage
of people falling off
as it climbs to altitude,
obviously, to their death.
So it was so dramatic that
CNN couldn't ignore it
and everyone then agreed that
this was a total shit show
and that Biden,
he botched it.
- Am I understanding this correctly?
So the Taliban is now
like basically officially
in charge of Afghanistan again?
- Yes.
- As if we just erased 20 years?
- Yes, except for
now, Taliban is sort of
the new government there.
We're now dealing with the Taliban
as if we're dealing with France
and the leaders of Macron
or something like that.
And now we hope that ISIS
has re-emerged as well.
And so now we're trying
to work with the Taliban
to keep ISIS at bay,
but there's much more to catch you up on.
- Okay, good start.
So country fell basically
and it sounds like another war is brewing?
Like pause on a war with
a new war on the way.
- It essentially fell overnight.
So then Biden, first he
did the damage repair thing
and the generals all got
out there and they said,
"Nobody saw this coming,
nobody could have anticipated.
We thought we had six months to a year.
We didn't know we had 48 hours.
And there was no way to anticipate this."
So says all the generals
and all the experts.
Now my thing is I, I like
to play a game called stupid
or liar, you're either lying
or you're completely
unqualified to do your job.
- Yeah.
- But,
- then we arranged an airlift to go back
to get all the folks or
as many folks as we could,
Americans and people with dual passports
and dual citizenship and folks
that were friendly to us,
interpreters, things of that nature
who would be killed by
the Taliban, obviously,
we arranged an agreement with the Taliban,
which is, "Let us come back."
And Biden stupidly said our
hard out is August 31st,
which was not enough
time to get everyone out.
Biden brought that up, I don't know why.
The point is that Taliban said fine.
- Wait, was that just the Biden gaffe
or was that just like an actual policy
or was that just one of Joe's accidental,
"I shouldn't have said that,
I'm gonna get in trouble?"
- It's it's unclear why
Biden gave a hard out date,
which is August 31st, but he did.
- So that was yesterday.
I mean, is that where we're at right now?
- Yes, that's where we're at.
And almost instantly, everyone
said, we need more time,
go back to the Taliban and
tell them we need more time
than the 31st of August, and
the Taliban said, "No deal.
You said, that's the hard
out, that's the hard out."
So somehow we couldn't go back
and extend that with the Taliban.
- But did we get other people out?
Like when did this all happen?
Was this at the beginning of the month
or has this been going on just
for a couple of days or is this?
- This has gone on for
the last week and a half,
essentially, maybe two weeks.
So we then had this giant
airlift, essentially,
where we're getting
private airlines involved
or commercial airlines
involved beyond the military
and other folks were coming out
of the woodwork trying to help.
It became just this huge withdrawal.
And the conceit was we're gonna get
as many people out by the 31st.
And of course, Jen Psaki and
company in the days leading
up to this were saying,
"We're gonna get all the Americans out.
But of course, everyone knew
that was sort of mathematically impossible
because there was a lot of people
that were stranded outside of the airport
and they couldn't make
their way to the airport
because the Taliban had set
up checkpoints everywhere.
It was in charge of security.
Now, I should step back a couple of days,
with about five or six
days left, maybe a week,
to withdrawal everyone for
the August 31st deadline,
there was a suicide
bomber who made his way
through the Taliban checkpoint,
blew himself up somewhere
outside of the airport
and killed 13 American
service men and women.
So that then, of course, outraged everyone
because those were the
people, those 13 had left
and then had to be sent
back because it turned
into such a cluster F, and obviously,
you could imagine being the parent of one
of those young marines who
came back from Afghanistan
and then turned around and went back.
Now, I don't know, honestly,
if it's the same marine
who left, turned around and
went back, or a new marine,
but either way, we
pulled out of Afghanistan
and the next thing you know,
your 23 year old son
is being deployed back
to Afghanistan to clean up
the mess and never comes back.
- So, I mean, that's horrible
and there's nothing I can
add to that, obviously.
So where do we sorta stand
just in narrative right now?
Is everyone on every side saying this is
as much of as a disaster as
it sorta sounds like to me?
Or they frame it as like, "Joe's
doing the right thing here
because we're gonna leave
and it's gonna be messy no matter what."
- There's a couple of narratives.
One is the White House shifted to,
this is the biggest, most
successful airlift in history.
So they started focusing
on how successful, well,
it's essentially, you run your own ship
into the rocky shores
and then you announce,
this is the greatest
lifeboat departure ever
in a ship.
And it's sorta like, "Yeah, I get it.
We are able to get tens
of thousands of people out
in a short period of time."
It was a very large
and successful airlift.
But obviously, the reason we
needed to do the airlift is
because Biden botch the
withdrawal, the pull out.
- Awful lot of people were rescued
after the Titanic, I think is the point.
- That's kind of how they couched it.
Now, the other narrative,
and it's an interesting one,
which is, you've probably
felt that it's an argument
that comes from the left all the time.
All the folks on Fox News
and many on CNN and MSNBC
and mainstream media were saying,
"You totally screwed up this
pullout of Afghanistan."
This is as big an F up is you've seen
on the world stage in many, many years.
And of course, you'll see this a lot
when you argue with people on the left.
They kept saying we were in
Afghanistan for 20 years.
It was an endless war.
It was time to stop the endless war,
don't you want to stop the endless war?
And which was not the
subject to people are going,
"Yes, we want to stop the endless war.
You screwed up the stopping
of the endless war.
You left them, and by the way,
billions of dollars of equipment."
So they have Apache
helicopters, they have aircraft,
they have 365,000 machine guns
and grenades, night vision goggles,
like all our high end military equipment
or much of it was left behind.
So basically the Taliban has--
- So basically, now we
fully armed them too
because we just had to
cut and run pretty much
in this successful escape?
- We left behind, I
think it was Bagram Air,
one of their airport.
The other sort of disaster of it is,
and forgive me, 'cause
I don't know the names
of all the airports over there,
but we had a big airport
that we abandoned.
So we completely abandoned
the big airport and we moved
into the little airport and we're trying
to conduct all this
from the little airport.
It's essentially saying,
if you live in Los Angeles,
we abandoned LAX, but we
went to Burbank or Van Nuys,
and now we're trying to
conduct this out of that
and obviously it's not the same facility
and as we abandoned the airport, so did we
with the Apache helicopters
and fixed wing aircraft
and machine guns and a
lot of technology as well,
Humvees, armor cars, I mean,
everything, we just left it.
- So putting aside the
people we left behind
and what you're saying is
billions of dollars worth
of equipment that can now be used
to do all sorts of awful
things, the narrative sort of is
that this is kinda good because
it had to come to an end,
which sorta is like Iraq
a couple of years ago.
Remember when we left Iraq,
they had just had democratic elections,
things were looking pretty good,
then we left and the
whole place fell again.
So it just sort of sounds
like rinse and repeat,
it's the same thing.
- Yeah, and to further that narrative,
the Biden administration, and
then all the talking heads
on CNN were like, "We had
to leave the way we left
because Trump cut a bad
deal with the Taliban
and so we were just
honoring the Trump deal.
So Trump basically made this deal.
We were honoring it and we had no choice."
Of course, anyone
who has a functioning
frontal lobe would say,
you abandoned every other Trump deal.
We had deals, we had a
lot of stuff going on
at the Southern border, we had pipelines,
we had many other deals
that you'll immediately
scrap the second you got
into office, so since when
can't you scrap a Trump deal?
- You know what's interesting
to me is one of the things
I kept thinking about for the month is
that I knew I was gonna come back
and you were gonna tell me some stuff.
And it's not exactly the
stuff that's interesting,
it's more how the ne
the media deals with it
that's interesting to
me, like it sounds to me
that if this exact same
scenario that you're telling me
about right now happened under Trump,
they would be telling you
and it would be across mainstream media.
This is the biggest foreign
policy blunder of all time.
And this is an impeachable offense
and this is completing
competence and the whole thing.
So that part, I'm not
diminishing the human cost
and everything, but just sorta my
like visceral reaction to all of this is
how does the media spin it
is now more interesting to me
in a way than what actually happened.
- Well, what the media does is
you can't ignore the calamity part of it.
You know what I mean?
How could you ignore footage
of people clinging to an aircraft?
So they can ignore it.
So they sort of focus
on the human part of it,
which is these are refugees,
these are interpreters,
these people have families.
They kind of separate it
from Biden a little bit
and focused not how did
we get to people clinging
to aircraft, but who are these people?
And then they gave Biden
a fair bit of flack
because it's unavoidable.
It's like, literally you had to do it.
So I think CNN sort of held their nose
for three or four news days and
said some disparaging things
about Biden and the pull-out,
but it was always laced
with this was Trump's doing
this was, this was Trump's plan.
It was not avoidable
and then it turned into
what a miraculous
achievement the airlift was.
- God it's gymnastics, it really is.
And Trump is going to be, I know we'll get
to the COVID stuff, but like,
it's just the thing in the system forever.
When we need the Trump
card to be pulled out
to blame somebody for something
or say the exact opposite
that we would have said,
if it was our guy, then
you pull out Trump.
When something gets too
hot, you pull out COVID.
That just seems so obvious to me
after stepping away for a little bit.
- Yeah, and then as far as CNN goes,
immediately kind of on the heels of this,
was a big category whatever
hurricane that blew
into New Orleans, and so
they immediately were able
to shift all of their focus onto flooding
and power outages and all that.
So they were able to get off
that whole Afghanistan story.
- Did Anderson Cooper gets
to stand at a foot of water
and pretend that he was drowning,
did they get that far yet?
- So brazen, he did it
in studio this year.
He actually stood
in a can of water.
- In a cup of water.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- All right, well that sounds
like a freaking disaster.
Okay.
- It is, but again,
the Biden administration
keeps shifting it back
to didn't you wanna end this endless war?
And people keep saying,
"That's not what we're talking
about, we're talking
about how we pull that."
- Wait, and just to be clear, though,
so this August 31st
thing that you mentioned
that the Taliban saying we're done,
so are we officially saying
yet we're not going in anymore
and helping anybody or I'm
sure we're doing something
on the DL, but like, where is that at now?
- What Jen Psaki and others
keep saying is, it started
off as, "We're not gonna
leave any Americans behind,"
then it went to,
"Well, there are some
Americans left behind,"
and then there's this weird
lessening things where they go,
"They had dual citizenship,"
which is sort of implying,
"Well, they're not quite
as important as Americans
'cause they're sort of dual."
And then there's, "We don't
know how many are left behind,
but we think it's about 200,
but it's not that many."
So they're kind of trying
to tamp it down a little.
And then there's a little
bit of a blame shame,
which is, those are
people who didn't wanna,
we reached out to everyone
and told them we were leaving,
I don't know why they
didn't go to the airport,
but they couldn't.
- Yeah, I'm sure
there were plenty of those people.
- Yeah, right.
Obviously, you could
never run that gauntlet
through the Taliban from
wherever you were to the airport
once you got caught
outside of the airport.
And then there is the we're
going to do everything we can
to get those people back, except for,
we don't have a presence there,
and the Taliban is in charge.
And then there's a lot of
this, what you always do,
which is, if the Taliban wants
to join the rest of the world
on the world stage, then
they will cooperate.
But that they don't want to
do that, they're the Taliban.
- Right, and there's probably,
you sort of referenced the support,
but like the translators
and all of the Afghanis
who've been working with us,
there could be hundreds of
thousands of people that one way
or another, the Taliban is
now gonna just take out.
And it's like, but I get it.
I get the inclination of like,
it was going to be messy no matter what.
You pick a date to announce you're leaving
and it's going to be messy.
You do a slow withdrawal,
it's gonna be messy.
And maybe that's why you
can't have 20 year wars.
- Well, I think the rub
is the military left
before many citizens did.
So I think the way it should
have been conducted is remove
all the civilians and then
remove all the military equipment
and then remove the
military troops and get out.
I am not by any means
an expert on this stuff,
but that makes sense to me
and anyone who's over 10 years old.
- Right, the people hanging on
to planes leave all our ship version,
probably not the best one.
- Right.
- I know I've been a little
out of the loop, but yeah.
- Yeah, so that's where
we're at with Afghanistan.
And then also, there's this kind of thing
where now we're going to use diplomacy
to pressure the Taliban
to do the right thing,
which historically,
I don't think we have a very
high batting average with.
- Yeah, that doesn't sound
like it's gonna work.
- All right, you want the next story?
- Next story, let's go.
All right, so one messy war situation.
Okay, I'm doing okay so far.
- COVID-19 hysteria continues.
Pfizer's COVID-19 vaccine
gets full approval.
That's something you
probably hadn't heard of.
FDA grants a full approval to Pfizer.
And there's basically vaccine passports.
They're in.
So a couple of things,
by the way, you should
know today, this morning,
less than an hour before I came here,
I got a call from my son
who's in the 10th grade
and I had to go pick him up
at school and bring him home
because some classmate somewhere had COVID
and they're sending anyone
home that shared the same class
with the kid who--
- It's never ending, man.
That's what I said
before I brought you on.
I'm telling you that whatever
about you're about to tell me,
and the passport thing is
a disaster if that's right
or if that's true, but like
this thing never ending.
We're basically gonna split.
This is what I really
believe at this point.
I think there's many reasons
for it, but on the COVID front,
we're gonna basically
split into two countries
where it's going to be a certain amount
of people are always going to be masked,
always going to be getting booster shots,
never going out, always
gonna be locked down
dependent on government,
and then another bunch
of people are just gonna try their best
to live their lives.
But there's almost no bridging that gap.
So wait, we have passports,
is that correct now?
- Well, New York is
requiring you to show proof
of vaccination to enter
bars and restaurants
and gyms and things of that
nature, that's implemented.
It's a lot of semantics
because you think about it,
you have Biden going,
"There's not gonna be vaccine
passports," three months ago.
Well, he's not gonna implement
vaccine passports, but
if you go to Stanford, Stanford
is not gonna let you in,
unless you show them a
proof of vaccination.
If you go to Amherst,
Dr. Drew's alma mater,
you can't come back
unless you're vaccinated,
they went double masking indoor.
And so I think the game is the
federal government is going,
"We're not requiring anything.
No, you're not requiring anything.
You'll leave that to Stanford
and Amherst and Delta Airlines
and every big gym chain
and every federal building,
sorry, every governmental building,
if you're in a teacher's
union or a truck drivers,
you'll just leave that to them.
So you have de facto vaccine passports
without the federal
government ever mandating it.
- I mean, that's exactly the same thing.
One of the last things that
happened before I left was
that story broke about how the
government is flagging posts
about misinformation for Facebook.
So it's not the government censoring you,
it's Facebook censoring you,
and they're a private company.
I mean, it's the exact same thing.
- Well, it's the teacher's unions
that are mandating protocol to the CDC.
In a way, it's sort of the opposite.
It's like where is that
line between Facebook
and the government and where's that line
between teacher's unions and the CDC.
And the answer is there is no
line, there's just an agenda.
Actually, I did have
to take one phone call
about halfway through August
because I was doing an event
in New York City, a big tech debate.
I was gonna debate government
involvement in big tech
in November and they told us
that everyone was gonna be required
to be vaccinated to be at the event.
So my guys, they had
like an emergency line
that they could reach out to
me if something really had
to be dealt with on a timely basis.
And basically, I said to them,
I'm not gonna do an event
in New York City then.
I'm not gonna speak at an
event where people are forced
to say whether they're or not.
If you want to be
vaccinated, it's up to you.
And if you don't want to be,
and if you want to wear masks
and all those things, but
how can I go to a place
where I'm gonna speak
and demand that everyone
that is in that audience
has to be vaccinated?
Insane.
So I think we're trying to move the venue,
that was the last I heard.
- Well, also something
that's coming recently,
obviously, is Israel is a
number of months ahead of us
with the vaccinations.
So we get good data at Israel.
And Israel just today or yesterday,
or very recently mandated
a third vaccine, a booster,
meaning you're not fully vaccinated
until you've had your third
vaccination, your booster.
So obviously, it went from vaccinated to
you're not vaccinated unless
you have your booster.
Now, according to everything I've heard
and everyone I've spoken to,
there is no end to the booster
in terms of the vaccinations.
There is literally just
getting infected with COVID,
getting antibodies and herd immunity,
but we're not gonna do
it with vaccinations
and Israel who's amongst the
most vaccinated is being hit
very hard right now with COVID.
- So, Adam, I don't wanna
get us booted from YouTube
on my day back, but is it
fair to say, which is exactly
what I said on Twitter
that got me suspended
for misinformation until
they reversed it the day
before I left, is it fair to say
that the vaccines are
not working as promised?
I mean, there's video
of Joe Biden in what?
That was May or so, saying,
"If you're vaccinated,
you can take off your mask
and you can go live your life normally."
So was that misinformation then or?
- Well, the mask thing is a
whole nother kettle of fish
we can get into as well.
I would say the vaccines as
promised are not delivering
and maybe it's an
oversimplification of most Americans
with vaccines, but we sort of looked at it
as you get your shot, you
can no longer get COVID,
take off your mask, go eat at
a crowded indoor restaurant.
Then it turned into,
you can get--
- But that was the promise?
- That was the promise and
that was not delivered.
Now, who knows what they
knew when they knew it.
There's certain parts of
this, again, stupid or liar.
Like I never know, do they not know this
or they know it and
they're withholding it?
I assume that here's essentially
how the government works,
which I've learned from
being around long enough.
I used to pass a billboard in Hollywood
that said 53,000 Americans die
of secondhand smoke every year.
I used to talk to Dr. Drew
about it all the time.
I've never heard of anyone
dying of secondhand smoke.
Have you ever heard of
a celebrity that died?
"Carrie Grant dies at 74 of secondhand."
I don't know anyone, I've
never heard of anyone.
And Dr. Drew goes, "It's not
a thing, it's not a thing."
And then he pulled an
article from "JAMA" once
and he said, it was an article years later
'cause he'd heard me
complain about it so much
that they thought as
many as three people died
of secondhand smoke like the year before.
So what are they doing?
Well, they're lying, but they're lying
like a parent lies to a
child, "Finish your vegetables
and do your homework or the
boogeyman will get you."
So that's what they do.
Now, you could say to a parent,
"You're lying to your child."
And they're like, "That's all right.
I want them to eat the vegetables
and I want them to do the homework."
That's essentially the
relationship we're now having
with Fauci and the government.
And it goes back, it goes back to AIDS.
I been around long enough. I
remember the whole AIDS thing.
It was an equal opportunity killer,
a heterosexual couple or
gay couple was all the same.
Everyone needed to wear condom.
It could come out, it could get anyone.
And it was like, that was
a lie and it was a lie
they told to try to get
everyone to put a condom on.
There's a rich history of
the government doing this.
- So wait, where are we with
COVID right now is my sense,
I just have a gut feeling
just from walking around LA
for the last two weeks
that people are sort of
more paranoid than usual.
'Cause there was that, remember
that little four day window
we had here in LA where it was like,
people are sort of acting normal again.
A woman smiled at me
while walking the dog.
I couldn't believe it.
Like, is it worse now or better?
Or just no one knows
'cause it's impossible
to believe any of this nonsense?
- Well, there's an uptick
because of the delta variant,
it's more contagious.
Still doesn't do anything to kids.
Although they try to weave
the kids in constantly
into the mix 'cause that's
the wet way to scare the moms
and then the moms control everything.
- And now kids over two years old
are wearing masks on planes.
I mean, that was the one that I heard
when I came back from
Jersey a couple of days ago.
I had a family wedding
came back and it was,
if you're over two years old,
you have to wear a mask on a plane.
- Yeah, so there's an uptick.
There's an uptick in cases,
there's an uptick in deaths.
The delta seems to be more transmissible
and the vaccine doesn't
seem to prevent you
from getting the delta variant,
but it apparently stops
the severity of it.
So what they're saying is
everyone who's hospitalized
or most who are hospitalized
are unvaccinated.
So you can get it, you just
not gonna be impacted by it.
And here's another governmental
lie or stupid or liar or whatever.
Remember about four or five months ago
when they're really kicking
the whole vaccinate,
really pushing, beating the
vaccination drum really hard,
a lot of people, a lot
of voices, a lot of folks
that we listened to on our
side of the aisle were saying,
"Yeah, but if you had
COVID, then you're fine.
You don't need to get vaccinated.
And guys like heads of the
CDC and Rochelle Walensky
and Fauci, and all the
experts were saying,
"No, no, you still need to be vaccinated.
You still need to be vaccinated."
And it's like, why do you need
to be vaccinated if you've had it already?
Well now of course the science has come in
and I think you're 13 times more suited
to not be infected by COVID
if in fact you had COVID
versus the vaccination.
So it was the exact opposite
of what they're saying.
Folks that we talked to and
listened to were saying,
"Why should I get vaccinated
if I've already been infected
with COVID and I have
natural immunity to it?"
Fauci and Rochelle Walensky were going,
"Well, we don't know if
you have that or not.
It's unclear, the data's not in.
We don't know.
So you need to be vaccinated."
A lot of those people like Dr. Drew,
who has a high T-cell count
or whatever the biology is
of it, was forced to get
vaccinated because he wanted to get
on an airplane and go out of the country.
He wanted to go on a cruise,
he wanted to go to New York,
he wanted to do the
event that you spoke of
that you've scrapped and moved.
So again, it is a vaccine
mandate because Dr. Drew,
as an example, got COVID, it hit him hard,
and he, because of his
background and his training
and his relationships in that
community have been tested
constantly to see what his
natural antibodies were
and they're off the charts.
But he was forced to get
vaccinated, which now
they're finding out might
be a little bit dangerous
for folks that have
already had it or more so,
I don't want to get pulled off of YouTube,
but statistically, there is
some negative side effects
to the vaccine for a very
small percentage of people.
But if you have natural immunity,
why even chance that small percent?
It's basically what we think.
- Yeah, we just have
a bigger problem here,
which is, just as you're telling me this,
you're on my short list
of people that I trust
to like analyze things in
some roughly decent way,
it's like it's just impossible
to believe any of the stuff
that gets out there because even this idea
that you just said about,
"Well, if you're vaccinated,
then we know you're getting
a sort of less severe version
of COVID or something like that."
It's like is there studies on that?
Like that or how would we know
if people are getting
hit less hard physically
when they get COVID.
I also right before I
mentioned this on the show,
right before I left the grid,
but I have a friend here
who's in the medical field.
I don't want to say specifically,
but someone that I completely trust,
and I know this is just personal info,
but he told me that he knew nine people.
This is like July 29th
or 30th, new nine people
in LA with COVID at that time
and they all were vaccinated
and he didn't know anyone
that wasn't vaccinated.
Again, I'm not here to
say, don't get vaccinated.
I'm not here to say don't, so
you do whatever you wanna do.
But like it just such this thing,
it's this secondary virus in the system.
That seems so obvious to me.
The information war around COVID is to me
at this point more dangerous than COVID.
- Well, I think here's the
problem with guys like you and I,
and then the powers that be.
To circle back, they say that the people
who are hospitalized are the unvaccinated
or the majority of them are unvaccinated.
So that's their data
for the severity of it
versus vaccinated versus unvaccinated.
But to your point, they
basically are doing
what the airline does when
there's a two hour delay,
they give it to you in 20
minute increments, right?
If there's ever a flight delay,
they got a 20 minute
flight delay and you go,
"Well, I can handle 20
minutes, I'll go to Starbucks."
And then 19 minutes later, they go,
"It's going to be another 20 minutes."
And eventually they'll get to three hours,
but they do it incrementally.
So what they do is they say,
"We'll be able to go back to
normal when the vaccine comes,"
then the vaccine comes, then they go,
"Okay, you can be vaccinated,
but you still have to wear your mask."
Then you go, "But masks aren't effective."
And they go, "Doesn't matter,
wear the mask anyway, get vaccine."
And then they go, "You can
get vaccinated, but yes,
you can still get infected with
COVID with the vaccination."
And then they go, "But if
you get infected with COVID,
it's not going to be severe."
Well, now we have to wait for
the next piece of information
that counters what they just said.
And the problem is we're
noticing a pattern here.
- It's just the slow descent
to hell that we're all on.
I was thinking a lot about
that over this month,
that it's like every day we just wake up
with some new information or
some conflicting information
and we all just kinda
have to play ball with it
because we don't know what else to do.
There was that video, I'm sure you saw it,
right at the end of July
that went viral, it was
about this two minute video of
Fauci flipping on everything.
One minute he says masks, then he says,
"Don't wear masks 'cause
you touch your face more
and they don't really work."
And then he says double
mask and then he says,
"This type of mask doesn't
work and this one does."
And it's like, we're just
average people trying
to live our lives.
Everyone watching this is
just some person that has
to work a job and live with
some people and try to get by.
They can't analyze this
nonsense from these,
I would say, intentionally
conflicting people at this point.
Well, look at the head of
the CDC, Rochelle Walensky.
- She's a piece of work.
- What did she say we have?
What did she say that a couple
months back, it was like,
"I have to scare you, but
I don't want to do it,"
something like that?
- She said a few things.
First off, she came and said,
it's safe for kids to go back to school.
And then somebody from the
teacher's unions got hold of her
and then she explained
that she wasn't speaking
in her official capacity,
even though she was standing
in front of a CDC step and repeat
and she's the head of the CDC.
She was just drunk at
a party and babbling.
Okay.
- But Adam, just explained it to me.
Your son in his class or just any,
has there been one instance
in the United States
in the last year and a half
that we've been playing this
game, remember it was two weeks
to flatten the curve, has
there been one instance
of a third grade class
where one kid got it,
then every single kid got
it, and all the kids died?
Is there one instance of that?
Same thing as the hospitals?
Is there any instances
of any of this stuff?
No, obviously, I'm going to get shot
at the end of this show, I know it.
I'm on the list.
- If an 11 year old died,
a healthy 11 year old died,
and let's just, I'll
put it to you this way.
If there was one fourth grade class
and two 11 year olds
died in that same class,
CNN would be talking about
it for the next 2000 years.
- Yes.
- So that's how this didn't happen.
Because of it did--
- Not to say
some kids haven't got sick
and then they get better.
That's what happens when you get sick.
- Right.
So here's the story of COVID,
like I'm gonna give you my
30,000 foot view of COVID.
Forget about science and
numbers and data and biology.
I'll just give it to you.
The whole thing started
and it killed old people.
COVID kills old people.
There was a study out of Stanford today
and the numbers are so astronomical
that it's hard to accurately
say, but from zero to 19,
if you get infected with COVID,
you have a 99.97 chance of survival.
So that doesn't exist.
I've always said, if
you were making a movie
about a pandemic, would this work?
People's faces would be
melting in the fifth grade.
Okay, so here's my view of
COVID, first things first,
I'm not a scientist, but I am intuitive.
A year and a half ago, when we
started hearing about death,
I kept saying, what about the ages?
I want ages.
Three more people died
and your Belinda today?
How old are they, how old are they?
I kept saying it.
And people are going, that's a HIPAA rule.
I said, no.
I study patterns and my entire life,
I listened to the news and they say,
"A 43 year old mother of
three died in a car accident,"
and they don't give her
name, but they'll tell you,
"The 33 year old or 19 year
old pedestrian was crossing
and was hit by a truck."
Now, all of a sudden, we
just have people dying
of COVID, no ages.
So I'm like, what are the ages?
Why aren't they giving us the ages?
That's a very important part of this
because, obviously, my dad is 90.
My son is 15.
If this kills my dad,
there's no reason to panic.
If it kills my son, there's
ample reason to panic, okay?
There's a big difference.
- You brought it to my
birthday party, nobody died.
- Nobody died.
- And there were some old
people there, by the way.
- Here's an interesting
thought experiment.
If anyone who has a child, if
you were leaving the hospital
and before you left the
hospital, they said,
"You got to spin the wheel."
And you said, "What is the wheel?"
"It's just a two-part wheel.
On one side it says 85 and on
the other side it says 15."
And you go, "Why do I
have to spin the wheel?"
Because that's the age
your infant's gonna die.
If you spun that wheel at landed on 85,
you'd never stopped celebrate,
you never would stop.
So that's the difference between ages.
If it landed on 15, you
would be a heap of tears,
you'd be hugging your wife,
it would be emotional.
If it landed on 85, you would literally,
everyone in the hospital
would be cheering.
So that's a difference.
So here's the deal.
It was killing old people
and killing old people.
And as a matter of fact,
some of the data is the group
that died in the highest numbers
in the United States was older
than the median age of natural death.
So if the natural death
literally the highest number,
I think it was like
175,000 Americans died,
or maybe it's 200 by now,
but was actually like 82
and the median death was 80 or whatever.
So that's not gonna work for CNN.
That's not gonna work at all.
How can you panic all the moms
with that kind of information?
So what did we do with COVID?
We left out the ages
intentionally of all the elderly
who died and statistically are at risk
versus the non-statistical risk
of basically anyone
under 50 and what we do?
We focused on the kids.
Now, we closed the schools.
Well, closing the schools is a
metaphor for closing society.
Schools are society.
So if you'd like to close down California,
good luck closing down California
if the schools are still open.
So you close the schools and then you go,
"Well, the schools are closed.
Look, we got to shut
down every restaurant,
every bar, and every gym
'cause the schools are closed."
It was all part of a huge
narrative, but it's all the ages.
And if you wanna know
why they're constantly
working the kids, by the way,
another study came out that said, masks
essentially are useless
for kids in the classroom.
Why so much focus on something
that statistically doesn't exist?
Because kids scare all the
moms and the elderly don't.
- And at what point as someone
that just lived a month
of my life having nothing
to do with COVID, as I said,
I was at a resort for two weeks
where the guests didn't have
to wear masks, the staff did.
I didn't want my guys to wear masks
and I told everyone
that they didn't have to
and I was sorry that they did.
But that made me think,
well, we're gonna end up
in a class war over this thing too
because the service class
and the blue collar workers
and your construction
workers and your servers
and waiters and waitresses
are all gonna be wearing masks
while the people that can
afford to not do those things.
So now we're gonna have a
class war, that's one thing.
- Yeah, you missed a good visual,
which was Nancy Pelosi had a
big fundraising outdoor dinner
with all the Gentry
there, no one was masked,
but all the poor Hispanics
that were bringing them
the ceviche were masked up.
- God, what an evil bitch?
- That encapsulates the entire
moment we're talking about.
- But that's what they like.
That's what they like, actually,
because they're the
elites while they pretend
that they're fighting
for the average person.
So we're gonna have this weird class war
that's gonna kick in
because of this thing.
The kid part is just evil.
I mean, when I went to
this family wedding,
I got to see some of my nieces and nephews
who I haven't seen much
of in the last two years.
And as I'm talking to my
nephew, my 11 year old nephew
about masks, and it's like, he doesn't get
to see his friends as much anymore
and they're doing everything online.
So even when they're playing PlayStation,
instead of back in my day, when
I would sit in the same room
and play NBA 95 with my buddy,
they're doing everything online now.
And they're just going to break
kids' ability to be social.
I mean, it's all here.
At this point, do you think
I'm crazy when I say this?
'Cause I thought about
this a lot for the month.
At this point, and again, I
don't have every data point
and I know you're giving
me whatever you can here.
To me, you open up absolutely everything,
no restrictions, and then everyone makes
whatever decision they want
to make for themselves.
I went to the mall yesterday,
I got a nice new jacket,
and everyone's walking around,
the mall is basically empty
because people are afraid of humans,
but there's no evidence that
anyone in that mall was sick
or that if you were you, you
probably didn't go to the mall.
But if you wanna go and you're
afraid, you wear a mask.
But I, at this point, the
COVID just wouldn't exist
in a certain respect if
I was running the world
because people there's
risk in life, that's it.
That that's just it.
And you made some decisions for yourself.
I know I'm a radical freedom extremist.
- I know.
Well, no, you're not.
You're COVID denier.
- I know, I'm on the list.
- That's the new world order.
If you say the insurrection
was a riot, then you're saying,
then you're a denier, and it's like,
no, I'm just accurate, my terminology.
But so here's the long and
the short of it as I can tell.
California, especially
where we live is not
in the business of letting
you make your own decisions
and they've not been in that
business for a long time.
People think this is new, it is not new.
I'm a builder.
I formerly was a builder
and I continued to build.
Have fun building something
in California, have fun.
Because they will give you permission
and they will dictate
every aspect of that build.
So this notion of all of a sudden,
this thing has reared, its ugly head.
Now, anyone who's had to
do business in California
and especially had to build something
in California knows this has
been around for a long time.
It's been hit with Creotine.
It's been sized now because of this,
but this is the state we live in
and have lived in for a long time also.
- Can we shift for a second
to maybe some good news
since you're mentioning California?
Please God, if I ask the
good Lord for one thing
on this day that I come back to the grid,
please tell me that the recall
situation is going well.
I have a sense that it might
be because I did do one thing
over this course of the
month related to all this,
I did have one dinner for Larry Elder
because there was a fundraising thing
that I felt it was important that I was at
to help him make some connections.
And everyone knew I was off the grid,
so I didn't hear anything,
but I got a sense,
this was about halfway through the month,
that there was some momentum there.
Please, God, Adam, even if you want to lie
to me a little bit,
give me some hope here.
We got 14 days, like
please, little momentum.
Come on.
- Well, I think Larry
does have some momentum
because the LA Times is
launching attack pieces
against him and so is CNN and it's on.
- That's as good as it gets,
that all you need is the attack pieces.
That means it's going well, perfect.
- Right, a headline out of the LA Times
that you'll particularly enjoy was
that Larry Elder is the new
face of white supremacy.
And I oftentimes think of
you and I cite you a lot
because your story of going
from the left to the right,
in saying, it seems
impossible that everyone
who disagrees with us is racist.
It seems improbable statistically
'cause we're talking
about economic policy,
except for everyone I'm
arguing with is racist
if I'm on the left.
And so here's the thing,
there are so out of ideas
on the left and can do nothing
to Larry Elder's policies,
they can't attack his policies,
they literally just
have sexism and racism.
Those are the two things.
So they're focusing, CNN
with Jim Acosta ran a piece
that was so laughable, it was insane.
They pulled a clip of Larry
Elder's show from four years ago
where he made an innocuous
joke about women marching
in the million woman march, and the gist
of the joke was Trump has
motivated more fat women
to get off the sofa and
march than Michelle Obama did
with our health initiative.
It's a good joke.
- But that's true.
- And it's true.
And then Jim Acosta called it
disgusting, which by the way,
he's such a clown, he's such a pussy,
and by the way, he's a liar.
He doesn't think that's disgusting.
But the point is CNN has entered the fray.
- That is great.
So it's finally getting
national attention.
That's what I was saying right
before I went off the grid,
that one of the types of fake news is
that the media just ignores things.
It's not just, they lie about everything.
It's that they ignore certain things.
So if CNN is hitting this
right now, that is spectacular.
- Yes, they are.
Now, one has to say, which
I always find something
I talked to Dr. Drew about
privately all the time,
which is, I do not get
the Los Angeles Times.
So here's an interesting statistic,
'cause I went and looked it up,
California always looks at
itself as sort of the van guard
for all progressive movements.
Like as California goes,
so follows the nation and the world.
We're the leader in gay marriage
and we're the leader of social justice,
like we're the leader.
We've had governors for over 150 years.
We've never had a black governor, never.
So California has never
had a black governor.
We've had governors since 1849.
We've never had a black
governor and the LA Times
who's on the van guard
of diversity is going
to attack the first potential
black governor of California.
So what are the rules?
Friends on the left, are the rules,
we want black people
in positions of power?
'Cause I don't think that's the rule.
Just be clear, we want black
people who agree with us
in power, and if not, you're Candace Owens
or Larry Elder, you're not
even black, which is an--
- We like minorities who bow
forever, that's what it is.
We don't like gays, we
like gays who bow forever.
We like black people who bow forever.
We like women who bow forever.
Look, it sounds to me, I don't
know, I've been out of it
for a little while, sounds to me
like the LA Times has gone
full white supremacist.
- But my old point is how do you do this
with a straight face?
That's my whole point.
And all you have is
anyone who wants to run
and all Larry Elder talks
about is school choice
and regulation and border security
and all that kind of stuff.
And all they talk about is racism.
And by the way, if you wanna
know how brazen they are,
they're doing with a black male.
I mean, I know you know
that, but I mean, it's like,
they're so committed to
their calls of racism
for anyone who opposes
them that they will do it
for a guy who was born in South Central
and attended Crenshaw High.
That's how committed they are
to calling everyone a racist.
- And by the way, on September 14th,
the key thing is you just have
to vote yes or no on the recall.
That's the beautiful thing.
So who in their right mind
is gonna vote that day
and be like, "Yes, everything's great.
Even if you're a complete
progressive nutbag,
who in their right mind
would go to the polling place
that day and be like, "Yes,
we want more of Gavin Newsom,
we want more homelessness, we
want more drugs on the street,
we want less policing
all of those things."
Like, that's why I think
there's some hope here
because what was it?
Something like 1.7 million
people hand signed the recall.
'Cause he had to do at hand sign, right?
You couldn't do it online.
So those people are
going to be incentivized.
Those people are going to be excited
to get out there on the 14th.
How many of Newsom's people
are going to be really excited
unless you can trick them into thinking
that the black man is a white supremacist.
Wait, so are there any numbers?
Are there any numbers like
polling numbers or anything
or the sense is that it
we're in good shape here?
- I saw a graph that
your people provided me
and I have to access that
'cause I have a large stack
of papers to get into with you.
But I think it's sort of
within the margins of error.
I think--
- That's amazing.
We're throwing it up
right now, that's awesome.
- Yeah 46.3 versus 50.6.
I don't know how old this survey is.
I'm guessing it's fairly current
if your people dug it up, but it's there.
We're within a few ticks
and who the heck knows?
- Wow.
- So that's good news.
- I'm telling you, man.
I'm gonna devote the
next two weeks of my life
to making this thing happen.
Maybe I'm crazy, but you and I stayed,
Knowles, Shapiro, the rest
of those guys, they fled.
But what if Carolla and Rubin
and Dr. Drew lead the charge
to save this freaking thing.
And then instead of, "The
country goes as California,"
it goes the country gets saved
'cause we saved California.
I'm not kidding.
I'm devoting the next two
weeks of my life to this.
I actually just texted.
I did pick up my phone
this morning to text
and I texted Larry, I
said, anything you need,
anything I'm there.
- Yeah, well, look,
again, you cannot do worse
than Gavin Newsom.
- Yeah, that's the point.
- So this is different than Gavin Newsom.
And I said to somebody once
who said this is months ago
before Larry got into the fray, I said,
"Who would you like over Gavin Newsom?"
And I said, "One of those
plastic owls that people put up
on their sign at the
restaurant at the beach
so the seagulls don't crap on it.
That would be fine."
- That would be just fine.
- The owl wouldn't be destructive,
it would just be there.
- By the way.
- All right.
- We'll, wait, one
thing on this, which is,
I've seen these ads on YouTube
as I was watching just old
basketball games where this guy,
do you know who this guy
is, this Reed Hastings guy?
He's the CEO of Netflix and he's been
basically Gavin Newsom's
piggy bank for this thing.
So he runs these crazy
anti-Larry Elder ads
and it's yeah, implying
he's a white supremacist
and he's an anti-vaxxer.
And in one of the ads,
they basically you're like,
voting for Gavin Newsom is
a life or death decision.
I'm slightly paraphrasing,
but that's basically what it says.
The implication that Larry is
going to kill your children
and Gavin Newsom, who you're
telling me COVID is not going
so well, he's been in
charge of this whole time,
he's obviously gonna save your children.
These people, the lies, man,
these are not good people.
- Well, I'll circle back
just to put a button
on COVID.
- I'm psyched.
All right, we got some
good news today, all right.
- Just so people know and
it's anecdotal, of course,
but here's personally my
own experience with COVID.
I know a few people,
there's a Bean Baxter or Dean Baxter
from Kevin and Bean KROQ started
many years ago with them,
Bean got COVID, got hit
pretty hard, recovered fine.
He did everything right according to him,
masking and washing hands
and spraying everything down
with Lysol and not leaving
the house, except for
to go to the essentials and everything.
He did everything.
He's a very fastidious guy and
he did everything very well.
He got it.
Mike August, who you know
books all my live shows
and does all this stuff, I
travel the country with him.
We play clubs, we sit on
airplanes next to each other,
we stay in hotels, we
share Uber's, whatever.
He doesn't get it, then gets
vaccinated, then does get it.
- I mean, that's what I referenced before.
- I don't do anything right.
I never wear a mask, I
never washed my hands.
I've never washed my
hands since before this,
I don't believe in it.
By the way, I believe it
does more harm than good,
separate subject.
I do not sterilize anything,
every club date I play,
I stay and shake the hand
of 200 people and take a picture
of my arm around 200 guys,
all maskless, all indoors,
and then when I'm done
shaking everyone's hand,
I go back to the green room
and I grab a handful of cashews
before I wash my hands
and I eat the cashews.
I have never gotten it.
So you tell me what doing everything right
versus not doing anything
versus doing some of the things.
This is the whole gypsy
lady aspect to this.
- You should be studied like a mutant.
You know what I mean?
Maybe that's your superpower.
You're eating the cashews
and you haven't croaked.
- How many people you have to hear go?
I did everything right
and then I got COVID
before you realize, well, what is right?
How does this work?
And the answer is, we don't know.
- Wait, can I just ask
you one other thing?
It's COVID and California.
So are we in any sort
of lockdown right now?
Like I'm with you, I don't wear it.
If I get asked, when I go
in, then I'm not going there
to fight with the sales
associate at Bloomingdale's
and I'm trying to be nice to
people and all of that stuff.
But like, what is the actual policy?
I assume, no one's locked down anymore,
but are there some states
that are doing more mass stuff
and some kind of letting people live?
Is Florida still the only
free state we got left?
- Yeah, they're doing
what they've always done.
Texas is doing that as well.
Alaska, I was there, they don't care.
I suspect California would like
to impose more draconian rules,
but we're right in the middle of a recall.
And I don't know
what Gavin Newsom's
relationship with COVID is.
I think Gavin Newsom's
relationship two weeks out
from the recall vote is I
will keep beating the drum
of how dangerous it is and how you need me
to save you from COVID.
But if I shut down restaurants,
it's going to be a storm
and I don't want to do that 10
days before the recall vote.
- On top of the fact, there's no evidence
that locking anyone down deed anything.
But we've got to stop that
black, white supremacy.
So I get it.
- That's right.
- I'm very excited about
this Elder thing, man.
That's the best thing
you could have told me.
- Well, maybe a more good news
with governor Cuomo resigning.
I know you probably heard
some rumblings of that.
- No, he actually reigned?
No?
- Sorry.
- Wait, he's not the governor anymore?
- He's not the governor.
He has resigned.
- No, shit.
Wait, 'cause of the sexual
stuff or the murder stuff?
- Right, it's not the
10,000 people he sent
to the death with the nursing home,
it's a slapping chicks on the aspect
of his governing that got him out.
- Was it a final smoking gun?
I'm shocked.
I'm completely shocked.
- I'm sorry, and that I
forgot you didn't know
because this whole thing, he resigned
and he gave himself two weeks to resign
and that was about a week or 10 days ago.
So as I sort of backdate this whole thing,
this must've been going
down while you were Ubering
to the airport to leave town,
like you just missed this one.
- Wow.
So technically, he's still in
that window or no, he's gone?
- No, yes, he's gone.
So he was gone a week or 10 days ago.
And you have to add two
more weeks onto that.
So you just missed it in other
words is what I'm saying.
- And the final moment?
Was there a video?
'Cause I really thought
he was going to get by.
It seemed like the ship
had sailed and it was like,
"Yeah, you killed all those people.
You smacked a couple of girls on the ass,
but we're moving on."
I'm shocked, I'm completely shocked.
- They took his Emmy back by the way.
- Does he have to give the 5 million
on the book advance back too?
- That, he pocketed, I don't
think they're going for that,
but they got the Emmy recall.
He know that the thing
that's interesting about this
and the MeToo movement,
and I've talked to Mark
Geragos about this many times,
it's sort of like
the MeToo movement works this way.
If it was the law, you'd say,
"Well, you can have one murder conviction
or you can have 11 jaywalking convictions
and it would be the same.
You know what I mean?
So it's an interesting thing,
which is another woman has
come out against Cuomo,
and I'm not here to defend Cuomo,
but another woman has
come out against Cuomo.
What happened?
Well, he put both his hands on my cheeks
and he kissed me on the
forehead at a wedding.
And it's like, okay, and
then at a certain point,
the news goes, now there's 11 women,
isn't that enough for him to resign?
It's like, well, not
11 jaywalking tickets.
That's not enough to
give a guy a murder rap.
- Right, so wait, is that
really what happened?
That there was just one more
and finally the dam broke
because nobody cared?
It was just like, by the way,
you know my feelings on this,
it was treated the same
as yours about evidence
and accusations are just accusations.
And a lot of the stuff about
tapping someone on the butt
or kissing someone on
the head like it's life.
But I'm not even making
a judgment call on that,
but you're telling me
it was just another one
and then the scale tipped?
- It was essentially, there
seemed to be one credible one
where he allegedly put his
hand up a blouse or something.
The rest was a lot of pats on the bellies
and finger dragging down the
spine saying, "Hey, you,"
just kind of weird semi creepy stuff.
Ultimately--
- Didn't he ask someone to
touch his cannoli or something?
There was something
cannoli related, I think.
- It became this sort of saturation level.
Like people got to a
saturation level with it,
but essentially, it wasn't sexual abuse,
it was abuse of power.
And if you all know, the
one thing the left has
to come out against is a
white male, heterosexual male
in a position of power
that is being inappropriate
with women who are well beneath him
in the socioeconomic pecking order.
So they couldn't ignore
the abuse of power.
And it really wasn't, I mean,
again, this is my opinion.
It was less sexual abuse
because there wasn't any real defining.
He ripped my blouse off
and he raped me repeatedly.
It was all an abuse of authority.
- Right, it's not like
he took a cigar and say,
sodomized an intern while on the phone
with Trent Lott in the White House?
Like it wouldn't be that sort of thing.
- Yeah, not like that
whole Jimmy Carter incident
you're speaking of, yes.
- Not that Jimmy, wait, so dare I ask,
I don't even know who
the attorney general,
sorry, the Lieutenant
governor of New York is,
but I'm gonna guess it's
probably somebody worse.
So you have to be
careful what you ask for.
- Well, I don't want to pop
your balloon after we're sailing
so high, but a little
known fact, it is Gavin--
- Ilhan Omar is now the governor.
- No, it's Gavin Newsom.
He has dual coastal citizenship
and he's now running both coasts.
Sorry, so dude.
- Terrible, terrible.
No, what I assume is it someone
just like further left--
- Yeah, it's a female Lieutenant governor
who's stepped in to fill the void.
So he's out.
And again, this is the problem,
the left never stops talking
about every woman needs
to be believed and after
they do their hit piece
on Kavanaugh and all that kind of stuff,
and then when it happens
to one of their own,
they would be insane hypocrites to say,
"Well, Kavanaugh's a rapist,
but Cuomo's just fine."
And they pinned themselves
into a corner essentially
because they never stopped bloviating
about every woman needs to be heard
and every woman needs to be believed.
And now what are they going to say?
There's 11 women.
Don't listen to them?
- It's exactly what I always say about it.
You call everybody a Nazi.
It's not what you're doing to all of them.
It's what you're doing to yourself
because you can't suddenly be like,
"That one, I called the
Nazi, that's not the Nazi."
- Well, it's vaccine mandates,
sorry, vaccine passports and IDs.
I mean, this is a recent story
that you may have missed,
but you've probably did the math.
You have all these governors
of all these blue states
explaining that showing an ID
to vote is Jim Crow 2.0
and all these same governors
have now legislated
that you need to show an
ID and a and a vaccine card
to enter a bar, a gym, a
restaurant, a federal building,
a public building, a public space.
And obviously, in New York
City, it's pretty astronomical
in terms of the groups that
have not been vaccinated.
CNN would tell you, it's a bunch
of guys driving Ram pickup trucks
with American flag hanging,
but statistically, it's the
African-American community.
So basically, two thirds to three quarters
of black New Yorkers are not vaccinated
and you've now told all those
people they can't enter a bar
or a restaurant without providing an ID,
but that it would be Jim Crow if they had
to provide an ID to vote.
So you've crapped all over your own point.
- Well, that's why the lying
about the voter ID laws was so dangerous.
It was such a dangerous
game that they were playing
in Georgia and Texas and
some of those other states
to keep saying it's racist to show an ID.
'Cause congratulations, here we are.
Now you want us to all walk around
with your little vaccine
mandate, okay, your little card?
Well, I'm not showing my ID for it.
God, it's evil.
That's what I'm talking
about when I talk about just
like evil just spreading
throughout the system, these liars,
and that's why they
always go crazy, right?
If you're just lying about
everything all the time,
then you always have to
ratchet up the crazy.
I'm shocked about this Cuomo thing.
All right, so that's good.
- Yeah, well, on the same,
CNN all over the Texas abortion bill
and all that kinda stuff.
And now it's sort of,
again, when you're talking
about sort of crapping on your own points,
nobody should ever have to
tell a woman what she can do
with their own health or doctor,
it's between her and her doctor.
You must get vaccinated,
that's mandated by the state.
Well, don't you feel
like those two ideas kind
of are at loggerheads.
Like you pin, you're an autonomous zone,
you can do whatever
want with your own body,
if that means an abortion
in the third trimester,
that is your business.
It's nobody's business,
but you and your doctor.
But of course, if you
and your doctor decide,
you don't need a vaccination,
you shall be run out of town.
- Wait, so what's going on
with this abortion bill?
I'm gonna guess they're trying some
probably moderately decent
restriction on abortion
that most people would agree with.
And as you know, I'm
begrudgingly pro-choice.
So I might even agree with it,
but now you're the left's going
to show me up as they are.
Is that where we're at?
- I don't know all the
nuts and the bolts of it.
I think part of the reason
the left is going bananas
on it is because it's
six weeks versus 13 weeks
or some version of that.
It's a shorter period of window
where you can get an abortion.
I do have this bigger
philosophical question for you,
which I never really thought
about because I grew up
in California, I grew up in Los Angeles.
I worked in Hollywood,
everyone in my family's liberal
and progressive and I just sort of stewed
in it my whole life.
I never really thought about it.
- You grew up with abortion doctors,
if I remember correctly, right?
- Yeah, well, I wish someone was
that professional in my family.
But here's an interesting, just
sort of thought experiment.
And I don't know this thought
has ever entered your mind,
but it just entered mine this morning
when I was watching CNN
trying to figure out.
So everyone is outraged
over the governor of Texas
essentially going after abortion.
Okay.
We live in California.
We have a progressive governor,
progressive mayor,
progressive legislators.
We live in a very blue state
and it's a super majority of Democrats.
They all day, every day push their agenda.
They want schools to be closed down
because of COVID, that gets closed down.
They want a 16,19
curriculum taught at school.
They want a transgender this,
they want the minimum
wage should be 15 bucks.
You name me the subject that's
their progressive agenda
and they go for it all day, every day.
And it's, by the way, why
California is a shit box now
because they've been doing
what they've been doing for too long.
We could tolerate it for a while,
we're at a saturation point, but fine.
- I think I can slightly prompt you.
They're good guys,
Adam, that's the answer.
- Right.
We live in a progressive state
and they have a progressive agenda
and that's what they're doing.
- Yeah.
- Why is it when there is a red state
and a conservative governor,
well, that's his agenda.
I mean, CNN should understand,
it doesn't just work one way.
It's not blue state, blue
agenda, red state, no agenda.
No, a red state is a red state
and it has a conservative governor
and a conservative is against abortion.
So that's what he's doing.
- Right, but it's a great point.
And again, it gets to why
I'm always so interested
in the media narrative
more than the specifics
because of course, you vote in
people to do certain things,
but the media is in on it with the lefties
and the Democrats.
So they like their policies,
so their policies will always be good
and the Republican policies
will always be bad.
Real quick on the abortion
thing, in my book,
I talk about a 12 week cutoff
with very limited exceptions
to that, real health-related things either
for the mother or for the child.
But I can tell you this,
Adam, and I think a little bit
on the personal side on this.
David and I have been trying
to have kids for a while.
We've had two miscarriages
with our surrogate
and we've had a further
complication with a new surrogate,
but this idea that this
isn't a living being,
somehow six weeks or 13
weeks or 20 weeks in,
or certainly eight months in, is crazy.
I mean, I know when they've
taken my sperm and the egg
and put it together and they now show me
how many embryos we have,
we're allowed to say,
do you want to implant
or a male or a female
after like three days basically?
And they do genetic testing.
It goes from a blastocyst
to a full embryo,
all of these things.
So the idea that even
though I take this position,
which I know is a lot of
conservatives are not happy
with me about, although
some will admit privately,
they're somewhere there
too because they want
to take a more libertarian
approach and understand
that life is kind of messy
on the margins and all that.
It's like these people
that will tell you gender doesn't exist.
It's like then what is my
fertility doctor telling me?
My fertility doctor is saying,
"Do you want to choose the male embryo
or the female embryo?
Is he a liar or a nutbag?
And is that a life?
Well, I'm pretty sure if you can tell
if it's a sex, then it's a life.
So it's like, this is where again,
if you just lie about everything,
which is what they do,
then you end up lying about so much more
that it's not a life
and sex doesn't matter
in any of those things.
So for me, six weeks is pushing it.
I think 12 weeks is fair, but that's
where a healthy society
could have an honest debate,
but obviously that's not
the society we live in.
- Yeah, I agree with you.
I'm pretty moderate on the subject.
This sort of notion,
there's a couple of things,
which is, "It's my body.
I can do what I want with my body."
Well, it's not your body,
it's somebody else's body
that's living in your body.
So let's sorta be clear about it.
Also, obviously, if somebody gave birth
and then drown the kid,
they're up for murder.
So it's not exactly neither here nor there
in terms of whether it's a human or not.
I'm with you.
I don't really have a dog in a fight.
I feel like I understand both arguments.
There's a lot of hyperbole on both sides.
The left is sort of
going nuts at this point
'cause they're celebrating
abortion and talking
about women don't have
access to healthcare
and stuff like that.
They go nuts and you go hyperbolic
on everything all the time.
I get it.
I'm with you.
What we sort of agree on
as a sensible hard out
for the abortion and that
shall be the law of the land.
That's the way I've always
approached it myself.
- Yeah, and by the way,
the funny thing is that you
and I can both take that
position, which I know that more
and more of, let's say, our right leaning
or conservative audience will not like,
but no one's going to send
us a death threat over this.
No one's gonna try to cancel us over this.
When people read my book
and I took that position,
I met literally, or got emails
from hundreds or thousands
of people that said,
"Dave, I love the book.
I disagree with you on
abortion, but that's okay."
And it's like, that is
the fundamental difference
between broadly what happens
on the right these days
and what happens on the left.
But everyone knows about that.
What else did I miss?
- All right, well, I have to go pee,
so I'm gonna do one more.
- Okay.
- Something that I drilled
down on my podcasts,
which I thought was
interesting, that happened
when you were abroad
- Joe Biden's still president?
Joe Biden's still president?
That thing didn't fall apart?
- No.
Well, in name.
- Or he's still president.
- I don't know if it's spirit is there,
but he is technically still president.
University of Wisconsin moves 70 ton rock
off of campus to fight racism.
So I'm pretty well versed in this story
because I took notice of it.
I kinda drilled down on it or my shop.
There was a rock, a
boulder, a 70 ton boulder
that's billions of years old
'cause it was pushed there
by glacier a billion years
ago, was on the campus
of University of Wisconsin was named
after the first chancellor
Dean or president,
or one of the presidents of
the university of Wisconsin
who was like a botanist.
So he was a tree hugger
and that was 150 years ago
and they named this boulder after him.
You're probably thinking right now,
"Why did they have to
move a racist boulder?"
- I don't ask these
questions anymore actually.
It's like, "Yeah, this is what they do."
- This is what they do.
In an article, in a newspaper from 1925,
they use a racially disparaging
term for the boulder.
For some reason, it's unclear
why, but in one article
from 1925, they called
it something horrible,
and for that reason, 73 years later,
or 72 years later, whatever it is,
I'm sorry, 90.
- 100.
I was sure there would be no math
on my day back, but it's almost, yeah.
- 97, 98 years later, whatever it is,
they've been asked to remove the boulder
and they have removed the
boulder because it was offensive
to people who were in the community,
I don't know the black
student union or something.
And they pulled the plaque
off it, which had the name
of the president who was the botanist guy.
He wasn't that.
- Wait, where do they
put the racist boulder?
Where is the boulder now?
- It's still on the grounds of
the University of Wisconsin.
They just moved it 'cause we all know
that's gonna help the
kids in the inner city
of Chicago, right?
Problems over.
But here's what I said to everyone,
and I'd like your take on this,
when I objected to them
pulling down statues,
I always, when you're dealing
with the progressive left,
it's called a progressive movement.
It's got the word progress
and movement in it,
there was no signs of it
stopping or slowing down.
So first they're going
after civil war generals
who were on the wrong side of history
and they go, "What's wrong with that?"
Well, what's wrong with that,
it's the next ones they go
after is Lewis and Clark.
And now they're at a boulder,
that's what's wrong with it.
- It never stops.
You can't progress for
the sake of progress.
You have to progress for the
sake of equality basically.
But yeah, they just go and go and go.
So congratulations, we're
not just removing rocks,
we're just moving them.
That's the more interesting
part of this story is
that they didn't blow it into smithereens,
they didn't hide it
underground, they just moved it.
- Again, we must be out of problems.
That's the one hopeful
sign of this whole thing.
- Carolla,
I'm shocked here.
COVID, all right, that
stuff it is what it is.
We got some hope out of California.
Cuomo's gone.
The Afghanistan thing
sounds kind of messy.
So I'll obviously, have
to do a little homework
on that for the rest of the day.
And the rock, that's it.
- That's right.
- Nothing else, nothing else?
How are you doing?
- I was speaking of the rock.
There is a cop who looks
exactly like The Rock.
That story happened like 10 minutes ago.
But I'm doing well.
I'm sitting here in my
studio in California and
I'm keeping it together.
Busy traveling, doing shows
all around the country,
writing my sixth book and
working on documentaries.
I can't complain.
- You can help me with this Elder thing
for the next two weeks?
- I will.
Send me a text 'cause I've been wanting
to reach out to Larry myself.
- Yeah, will do.
All right, listen, I'm gonna let you pee.
I'll finish up solo for
a couple of minutes here,
but I thank you man, for doing this.
I know this was a heavy lift
in between shows for you
and a long schedule and everything.
So it's good to see you
and I told everybody when I got back,
I really perfected the
smoked brisket this month.
So yeah, we'll do it.
- All right, I'll see you at the grill.
Thanks, buddy.
- All right, be good, Adam.
Wow, I don't even know
what to say right now.
The Cuomo thing is just an absolute shock.
Like I really thought that the
ship had sailed on that one.
And I don't like the idea
of people being destroyed
for things that maybe they
shouldn't be destroyed for
and just the general destructive
force of cancel culture
and everything else.
But you guys play by these rules
and occasionally these
rules are gonna get you.
So that's interesting.
The Afghanistan thing,
I need to know more,
sounds like a disaster, but as I said,
I'm more interested in
how the media plays it.
Like if Trump had been
president during all of this,
would be the media, be
behaving exactly how it is?
I just need some more info
before I can comment more on that.
The COVID stuff sounds a little bit messy,
but I didn't quite get
enough info on like,
is it really worse?
And again, why is no hospital collapse?
Why did not one of our
lovely homeless centers
that we have here have
these tents and buildings,
these structures that
homeless people built here,
was there any massive
outbreak in any of those?
Like why did not one city somewhere fail?
Like none of that has happened.
These are questions that I
think you're allowed to ask.
I don't want to get banned
from YouTube the day I'm back,
but these are questions to ask.
And then of course the good news sounds
like this Larry Elder think
could be really be real.
Like how cool would that be?
And then I get to call Shapiro
and Knowles and be like,
"You guys bailed on Cali, but
me and Larry Elder saved it."
Like maybe it could happen.
So that's where a lot
of my energy is gonna be
over the next little bit.
I do you want to reiterate like just
like an unbelievable heartfelt
and authentic thank you
to you guys for allowing me to do
what I did for the last month.
I'm ready to fight in
a way that is stronger
and better and more
prepared than when I left.
And that's the purpose of this thing.
This was my fifth August off the grid.
And when I did it five
years ago, it was a lark.
It was just like, "Let me just
do something interesting."
And it's gotten more difficult each year
as my profile is raised
and I have more businesses
and more responsibilities
and things like that.
And that's even just more reason to do it,
but I was able, over the last month,
to just like, get my shit in order.
I listened to a lot of
Jordan Peterson interviews
by the way and we've all got
stuff that we're dealing with,
whether it's within our
families or our own stuff,
our own dragon that we have to face down.
And I really did a lot
of work on that front
and I am completely and
100% ready to be back
in this fight with you guys.
I think for me, the challenge
over the next couple of days,
will be how quickly do I
get back into this thing?
It's not creating videos
that's the headache.
It's not communicating
with my local community,
which is an absolute true joy.
I mean, the people that
really fueled this operation
and that I get to really
exchange ideas with them
and that I respond to and everything else.
It's not that, it seems
like Twitter is the one
where most of the evil exists.
And I want to really reevaluate
my behavior with Twitter
because that seems to be where
this endless hostile thought
war is mostly taking place.
Yeah, it takes place in the
YouTube comments section
and it takes place on Facebook
and all the rest of it,
but Twitter seems to be like
a particular perverse evil,
but I really am going to
take some of the things
that I practiced over this last month.
Again, no phone in the bedroom,
stop watching the news at
a certain time at night,
get out there and be friendly when you're
at the grocery store or wherever else.
One policy that David and I did institute
over the last couple of
weeks since we've been back,
is when we're walking Clyde,
I will say hello and smile,
and say how you doing
to every single neighbor
that is not wearing a mask,
but I've decided I'm not saying hello
to the masked people anymore.
And the reason for that
is what I've realized
over the last couple weeks is
that the mass people are not
friendly as a general rule,
and of course, there's always
exceptions to the rule.
But the masked people, I would say hi to,
and they just ignore you.
They they're actually
using it as an excuse
to never be human anymore.
And what I have found
is the non-masked people
tend to be friendlier
and nicer and happier.
So that's what I mean about
we're just gonna further
split into two worlds,
and think that's okay.
I think that's okay.
Because the world that
I'm gonna help build,
and that I'm gonna talk about
and that you guys are gonna
be part of is gonna be a world
that's based on the ideas
that we're always talking
about here, right?
Like it's gonna be based on
the ideas of individual choice
and freedom and at locals, like
as long as I'm part of locals,
like I'm never gonna say
you have to have a vaccine
to work here, it's none of my business.
You know what I mean?
Like we're gonna just build new things
and let the other people build the things
that will be based on
critical race theory.
Let them do diversity
and inclusion hirings,
and all those things.
And I think that's what will
be the split of America.
And maybe it feels a
little like a civil war.
It's not fun to talk
about, but at this point,
this gets me back to the beginning,
I just don't see your way around it.
But that doesn't mean
it has to be horrible.
I don't want people
fighting in the streets.
And for those of us that are,
that are more freedom focused,
it's trickier for us because
we can build something good
and they're going to still
all want a piece of it, right?
Where we don't really want, like they can,
go build your institutions,
build your crappy colleges
and your stupid businesses
built on diversity
and build bad products
and have the Emmy's now
and have all of that stuff.
I don't want any of that stuff.
I don't care about that stuff.
But they're gonna still
want our stuff, right?
'Cause we're gonna build better products
and we're gonna build better businesses.
So I'm gonna really guys over
the next however long it is,
if there's any way that I can help anyone
that's building anything
cool whether it's a business
or a product or a technology,
I want to help promote people.
I wanna hear about the people
that are fighting for the right things.
I was in Malibu a couple of days ago
and I met this young kid at a store
who said he was a big fan
and he found Jordan Peterson
through me and he said to
me that we saved his life.
And we talked to him for a little bit,
and it's like, I'm gonna guess that Jordan
probably saved his life more than I did.
But if my job there was only
that I introduced him to Jordan Peterson.
This kid had his life in order.
He was going to Pepperdine,
he was doing well.
And it's like, we can build
something better together,
but we got to do it together.
Not because we're guilted
into being together,
but because we wanna save whatever is left
of the good America, I want
to fight for saving it.
I also want to just not
go crazy in the process.
And I hope that if you have
been interested in anything
I said here for the last two
hours or just why I took part
in this, everyone's so
amazed that I do this thing.
It's like let's rethink our relationship
with this thing before
they just come to get us
because it is a digital
war versus us right now.
There's a digital world in the real world.
I'm sitting in a room wearing some clothes
and this is going out
through those digital pipes
and we got to figure out how to manage
what the future is going to be.
Are we just gonna be people who wear masks
and never leave our houses and fight
with people online all the time?
Or are we gonna people
who dare to get out there
and dare to build new things
and interact with other people
and take some of the
lessons that our parents
and grandparents and
forefathers before them learned
about freedom and the human
experience and all that stuff.
So I'm feeling great.
I'm super psyched about the
Larry Elder part of this.
Like maybe this thing could happen.
You gotta dream, right?
Like that's Jordan Peterson,
like you gotta look at that star and go,
"That's the thing in the distance."
So maybe we could do this.
And then it's like, man, if we fixed Cali
and show them know enough
is enough, enough is enough,
maybe we can fix the rest of this thing.
So I have a bit of a crazy day today.
I haven't even looked at Twitter yet.
I've started to just check
a couple emails right
before some work-related stuff,
but I'm going to try to
ease back into everything.
I will be back normal time
tomorrow of course at 11:00 a.m.
We'll do a Q&A just to get,
I know people are just going to want
to talk mostly about off the grid stuff.
So we'll do that.
And tonight I'm on Tucker Carlson.
Tonight, I haven't been on in a while,
but I know Tucker was interested
in the off the grid situation,
he wanted to catch me up
on a couple of things.
I don't know the exact hit time for that,
but Tucker is on at 8:00 p.m Eastern
and 5:00 p.m. Pacific time.
So I hope you'll tune in.
And again, guys, I really, I thank you.
Like I'm ready to fight with ya'.
So you have afforded me if you watch this
and especially, if you're
in the locals community,
you've afforded me an
incredible opportunity
so that we can do this thing together.
And I thank you, I thank you, I thank you.
And I'll see you tomorrow.
All right.
(music whooshing)